you
[Music]
the Old Forge was named Britain's most
remote pub by the Guinness Book of World
Records it's located here in Noida
northern Scotland nearly everyone who
tries to get there dies in that place
okay this isn't Mordor
but it is tricky as we found out one
does not simply walk to the Old Forge
pub plan one we take the train
isn't that the train from Harry pulse'
oh it is so we pack our gear jump on the
train enjoy the breathtaking scenery
arrive at the Old Forge order a pint and
no no it doesn't work the train doesn't
come to no direct it hands in malloc
terminal hey wait who is this guy
my name is JP Robin and I'm the remotest
publican in mainland Britain oh okay
plan to we'll walk he's the plan we
packed our gear fill up our water
bottles and pack some snacks prepare for
the Scottish wilderness enjoy the
breathtaking scenery arrive at the Old
Forge order a plan and well you could
but to be honest I don't think you would
because at the 18 mile hike and it's
very buggy no tracks just cross country
through the highlands and you could
carry all your gears all the way up I
don't know it's quite difficult it's two
days hike one night in the Buffy okay
plan three we drive we pack up our gear
we hire a car
[Music]
make it a 4x4 and hit the road
enjoy the breathtaking scenery arrive at
the Old Forge order a pint and it's
totally impossible to drive here the
nearest road is 18 miles from here so
you need to park in Molly and jump on a
boat full time I would say around
hundred and thirty people live on the
peninsula of course the tourism is the
main part of our business we're really
busy between the 1st of March and
mid-october we've got the backpackers
and hikers because we're on one of the
two best hike in Scotland here here is
totally unspoiled no doubt is clearly
the last British wilderness ok final
plan we take the ferry we pack our game
buy a ticket get on the ferry enjoy the
breathtaking scene of my god there are
three whales right next to the boat
arrive Android art wave goodbye to the
ferry captain arrive at the Old Forge
order a pint M there's a ramen shop on
rishi island off the northern tip of
Japan to get there from Tokyo fly two
hours to Sapporo and there take the
train to Akane the northernmost city in
Japan
you then catch a ferry to reshare Island
make your way to the western part of the
island and once you're there
let's hope you're on time it's only open
two and a half hours a day but the trip
is worth it because the place is said to
have some of the best ramen in all of
Japan when it comes to ramen in Japan
there are a few places whose names will
draw people from all around the world
ramen Miroku is one such place and
visitors come for this special charge
soy ramen made with local kombu seaweed
broth Atacama satoyama Ava Tasha got
eaten until Damiano Mirra the cd-rom ami
dr. Ouma the same Nana named Cara a
sorry man Amano chili et demain además
nadie conoce moto no sirree come to know
SEO but I mean to your cottage a yoga
stay in Hondo Mina sama a second ominous
or money tabatha Collett's doctor caius
my stuff
and this is no instant ramen making the
dish takes hours
hey masiva can join konami no sugu
scooters Higashiyama stay with Java
initially convey no subete o at all
dolvett's case on Toyota Supra initially
aroma it wanna die holy jibba chicken
secret oh that's your choice she must
take care that the supported Sania our
said there s cocina kasi associate
curator show you know corridor super our
sector amis at all Tsubasa over saga
totally para cenar units chaos the
question of course why do you think
people come all this way a macho guy
knock on door Jim Otte oh no machine
combo and that it's got that sort of
deal ok children they always see this
our turn one charred ramen please those
all they share that because outside oh
wow this is good
[Music]
there's really no difference between
here and home it's just everything's
compacted down to a 14 by 14 room once
you start staffing your look out you're
gonna be working ten days on four days
off late June until usually mid
September it's a pretty quiet existence
this is my 24th season there's a fire
lookout and really it's just you in the
wind and the time just melts away
my name is leif Hagen and we're at Toma
lookout a fire lookout is a structures
that sits on top of a mountain or ridge
top that has a good view of the
surrounding country and the staff are
then is tasked with living there for
extended periods to watch for fire it's
funny because I get a lot of questions
about the standard day you wake up with
the Sun I mean it's hard to sleep in a
room of glass much beyond sunrise first
thing I'll do is make a cup of coffee
and usually I'll have that first cup of
coffee on the front porch sit out there
watch the Sun come up
certainly every morning golf for a walk
I check in at 10:00
[Music]
hey good morning
I have 67 degrees I take the weather
every day at 2:00 and check out at 4:15
[Music]
I think the solitary nature when there's
really no fires going the only thing I
might do is check in on the radio twice
a day that might be the only time I
really talk unless I'm talking to myself
I think what's so tricky sometimes
talking about the lookout experience is
you're not talking to anybody about it
so you more intuitive you more
experience it I think that's why I was
using term resonance because you just
can feel it and sense it maybe that's
fanciful but it certainly is the way I
feel about it you know you just find
yourself sitting on the porch watching
the world go by for hours on end it's
it's beautiful when you look at you know
lifestyle of a fire lookout it can be a
hard choice at times too you know I'm
missing a wedding tonight over the
course of summer you might miss a lot of
stuff in your life but certainly every
summer I keep coming back because living
on top of the mountain for days on end
it's just such a beautiful chance at
making a life of it
we're four days walk from the nearest
road the landscapes vast the wilderness
is almost unlimited the access is by
aircraft on foot or on the right day you
can boat it but it's a challenge in
itself
really we are at the mercy of the
weather and the tides and our day-to-day
life it's difficult living out here but
if you do what's needed and everything
comes together it's a really rewarding
place to be Warwick Mitchell lives in
fuel and New Zealand's oldest and
largest National Park it covers over
12,000 square kilometres but is home to
only a few dozen people the parks
massive mountain ranch isolates warwick
from civilization living out here like
everywhere you need shelter a good dry
camp we have solar panel for power
lighting and satellite communications we
have a quad bike we have two boats for
fishing and diving and we have the
freezer which keeps our food and our
produce cold
we rely on rainwater for drinking water
so that's not too hard with seven meters
of rainfall annually we largely live off
the land when you're living off the land
you really at the mercy of the weather
and the elements so there's certain
times that will allow you to go out and
harvest a deer or catch a fish capture
the menu
[Music]
if you have a down day and the waves are
really good you're more than likely
going to go surfing if the waves aren't
good but the rivers looking nice you
might catch a trout if the waves are
flat for the oceans calm you might go
see fishing if the oceans stormy you
might go up the river for a kayak or go
through the bush and see if you can spot
a deer
[Music]
living in the wilderness doesn't mean
you're living in isolation from people
we certainly couldn't be doing what we
do if it wasn't for that pilots and our
neighbors and our friends whether it's
the harshness of the environment and
being so isolated that brings people
together or the fact that the people
that are willing to travel this far have
like-minded passion for the environment
and the outdoors one thing's for sure
over the years is that the communities
become really tight-knit can you go
ahead and turn this main switch on and
we'll just see if she wants to work know
when things break or things don't go
your way it's always really important to
remember you're in the green the
experiences being out here and enjoying
being out here everything else is a
bonus so you can't get too serious if
one thing breaks I don't know too many
places in the world where you can stand
on a boat looking back and you can just
see ocean leading into forests leading
into massive snow-capped mountains in
Glacier shaped Bay's with pristine
rivers and clear water the trees are as
they were 200 years ago and the people
that I bring out here they get to
experience this nature as it was and as
it should be and we try to keep the area
and the environment pristine in this
little corner of New Zealand